this is about the only view that vitaliy
against off the outside world these days
she's too weak to walk more than a few
meters and has been suffering from
almost constant headaches and heavy nose
bleeding since the 5th of January that
was the day that she was hit by a rubber
bullet that fractured her cheekbone in
three places
no contender sera we were running down a
side street as 30 riot police were
chasing us banging their shields with
their batons it was really scary
suddenly another group of police blocked
our way and started shooting rubber
bullets at us I was hit on the cheek and
fell to the ground one of those grenades
with rubber bullets and tear gas
exploded next to me I couldn't hear
anymore I completely lost my bearings
and just sat there someone helped her to
get out of the crowd but what she saw
that day keeps her up at night the mere
sight of policemen now gives her panic
attacks the whole neighborhood when I
turned around I saw police here and
protesters with their batons they didn't
ask questions they just beat everyone it
reminded me of very dark periods of our
history so they they seemed crazed it
was frightening
it was unrestrained violence particular
they also have open limits she's not the
only demonstrator to have suffered
life-changing injuries more than 1,900
protesters have been wounded since the
demonstrations began three months ago
some people have lost eyes or hands
others have been left with mutilated
faces or limbs human rights groups say
the police have been getting more
violent the use of rubber bullets and
so-called sting ball grenades that
contain TNT high explosive and deliver a
deafening explosion of small rubber
balls is making the situation worse
boo-ki ziba he's under your ciske French
police could very easily keep protesters
under control with water cannons and
tear gas why shouldn't that be enough it
is for British German and Italian police
and they have to deal with extremely
violent demonstrations and seems to take
for granted that people will suffer
irreversible injuries inflicted by these
arms final more this really is a vaccine
but the police say they need the devices
to defend themselves and that 1,200
officers have also been injured in the
protests you know we never use our
battens without reason and only in
accordance with our regulations for
example if someone is resisting arrest
we need rubber bullets to keep
protesters at bay without them there
would be even more injured protests are
also more violent infiltrated by
extremists and there is no well-trained
security like union demonstrations to
keep such protesters under control okay
Tomo do debut or not - look we Battaglia
rejects these arguments she will sue the
French state for damages it's important
for me to take this to the European
Court of Justice I want people to know
what happened to us and how many of us
have been injured maybe the court will
order French police to be less violent
even if she wins the case Natalia has
lost faith in her country once she feels
better she's planning on leaving France
and the violence she has experienced